you know what was full I went to watch
another movie fall could not like it was
so hard to get a seene and you will not
you will not guess which film it was uh
it was Reservoir Dogs Wait what yeah
they were playing Reservoir Dogs in a
Japanese uh in Shinjuku like one of the
Shinjuku theaters and I wait Japanese
film gos kind of Bas though like I watch
even though qu Tarantino is one of my
favorite film I'd actually never watched
resir dogs really never seen it I just
never got round to it I don't know what
do you think of it it's funny I just
show I just showed C it a month ago she
[__] amazing yeah great aming but it
was insane cuz I kind of rocked up just
I rocked up 10 minutes late from the
screening time pretty much the movie
just started it literally I walked in as
they were doing the walk yeah oh you
missed the cafe you missed the cafe
scene yeah and I went home and watched
the cafe scene which I liked as well and
that was really fun but I missed the CAF
scene cuz I was late cuz I was I was
trying to get I was trying to buy Emily
some some birthday early birthday
present cuz I found a strawberry thing
that was perfect anyway so I was late
and I walked in and dude it was like a a
mission itself getting my seat cuz it
was totally full damn um and I was kind
of shocked cuz I haven't seen Japanese
theaters this full since I watched
Godzilla minus one right uh and even
before then I hadn't seen a full but it
was yeah insane full movie for Reservoir
Dogs in this year insane it was a great
movie as well it was really cool getting
to watch I feel like a film like this on
the big screen I feel like when you
watch kind of these old it's kind of
weird cuz I when you watch the classics
you kind of forget that we never really
will ever get the chance to experience
them in the theater God there are so
many films I would love to experience in
the theater even like something like in
glorious bastards or Pulp Fiction I'd
love to fiction I'd love to watch on big
screen with a popcorn like smothie
popcorn and uh it was really cool
getting to watch that I don't know why
Japan does this why do they just
randomly I know this is very common in
the UK and America they often have some
theaters that just replay Classics uh
which please keep keep doing uh I know a
lot of smaller theaters in Japan do that
for uh you know select films but only
with very very limited a huge theater
it's the
Shinjuku uh world it's one of the not
the Godzilla opposite the the the Toho
one oh yes yes yes so you kind of walk
out walk down the street and it's that
right yeah
yeah and I go there quite a lot cuz it's
just yeah that's a really good one um
yeah cuzz they they got I saw the AA
film there I think yeah it's kind of
great they play so many films and and if
the good thing about that area is that
if you want to watch movies in ja which
I recommend doing actually cuz it's much
better than Europe like America I think
America is actually better America
figured out the ideal Cinema experience
of course they like they're like full
relaxed chairs actually Shinjuku they
released they they released they opened
up the kabuko tower this giant [__]
Tower that's got tons of cool thing and
they have their own premium Cinema I do
quotation marks cuz um uh I is it not
premium well it's kind of hard to to
think of it as like they they're
marketing this as like the gigachad
goated theater experience of Japan I
it's pretty big and it is cool and there
is a there's a section that cost like a
hundred bucks right right 100 H sorry uh
10,000 Yen nearly nearly yeah about 80
70 bucks so it's about $60 right $607
and what you get in is that you get your
own booth and before it you get a lounge
experience so you can go to this Lounge
have a drink popcorn is free um like
it's so it's like a business Lounge at
an airort but yeah kind of Imagine a
business Lounge
and then you can this is it yeah this is
it it's literally a business Lou an
airport so you can just have un limited
popcorn and it's kind of small though
and so here's where I I this is the
honestly the sole reason I don't go back
is because you can only take one popcorn
into the theater and it's kind of small
and you can't refill it once the movie
starts and it's it's and to me it's like
dude I want popcorn throughout I will I
will get buy like way more popcorn that
I need cuz I just want to be I want to
be going at it um but you get these
booths that are it's kind of I don't
know if you can type in kukur to cinema
Booth chairs you get this booth and it
reclines but it only reclines like a
desk chair amount it doesn't fully
recline like the American ones I can
basically lie down yeah uh and I feel
like for the amount I'm paying it's not
really worth I mean there's not even a
picture I'm sure it's like premium for
Japan right for Japan it's premium yeah
uh but I feel like for 60 bucks it's
kind of not worth it's none of
those those are the basic chairs which
are pretty good they recline a little
bit of out there's one oh is that it
there uh up no you have it two more one
more yeah this is it this is it that's
the booth oh okay okay but it only
reclines like an average desk chair
would recline like this your legs go up
a little bit but not it's at the angle
that's like economy on a on an like a
plane where just it reclines but it's
just like not enough to like you're like
I'm still definitely sitting up it's
kind of like halfway and the legs only
come out slightly so you don't even feel
like your legs are really being
suspended by the chair you're still like
it's in this weird halfway where like
limbo yeah and I this is such a nitpick
but I think for $60 you should be like
giving me like in America I could pay
$20 for a full reclining Godlike [__]
like chair that's amazing and I [__]
go ham and then obviously I pay SE for
the popcorn but then afterwards they
have this uh actually it's kind of cool
after the cinema there is this Lounge
you can go to a different Lounge you pay
if you pay extra for the S tier you go
to the top top of the kabuko tower
basically and there is this uh kind of
other Lounge that is just like yeah
there's a giant window and you can just
see um I think uh Nish Nish Shinjuku
station all the trains going and see
like a really cool view of Shinjuku wait
what that's it that's it that's it
that's it that's it no no no no down
that one that one yeah click it yeah
that's it that's it I mean that's cool
and all but like you get one free drink
it's an alcoholic you be alcoholic but I
mean okay look that's cool I get it kind
of but at the same time it's like you
know what are you going to like you just
finished watching a film right here
here's what I think the idea is what are
you going to do you're going to sit
there in the lounge and being like so
what did you gentlem think about the
movie I think that's the point I think
the point is you watch you discuss it I
think you watch the so let's sayet on
let's say you go for dinner uh and then
you go and watch the movie I think it'sa
meant to be like the day like it's
the I actually like I I kind of vied
that cuz it was kind of nice you you
know like sometimes sometimes I do not
like when you you know you plan a cinema
day with your mates or something you
just leave and then you watch the film
you like hype up the film and then
everyone's like all right I'm going to
go home now and I'm like I feel like
I've missed half of the experience cuz
the whole point of watching with mates
is so you can banter about it afterwards
if I wasn't going to do that I would
have just gone by myself you know but I
I banned her about it on the way to the
station sorry I I banned her what if
it's a really good film and you need
like 2 hours to unpack it with well then
what I'll do is I'll go to like a cafe
near the station okay so this one you
have to you have to book it beforehand
um but yeah you get I think yeah what if
it's a [__] film and you're just like
stuck in the lounge like was all right
you get one free drink it's could be any
alcoholic beverage you you please and
then afterwards I think you have to pay
but I I'd rather go to Inakaya
afterwards and get as many alcoholic
drinks as you want you know what if you
want have a hard limit you're like I
want to be around this person for 1 hour
max let's give maybe don't go to the
cinema well no that's why I think like
it's a pretty good date if you wanted to
do it cuz it's like okay you can have
the dinner or whatever or you can just
go to the cinema have the loung before
andou after and then you can just have
the you know if you want to keep I'd do
it if it was a little cheaper I think I
think 60 bucks is quite a bit kind of
okay value I just think that I'm I I
really value a good chair uh and a and
pop from what you but from what gam talk
from what you have described it's not
even that good of a chair yeah um yeah
it's I it would have been perfect if he
had a better chair it's honestly
honestly I'm not kidding it's the
popcorn it's a deal breaker for me the
fact that I can't get more popcorn that
is true I refuse to go to the cinema if
I know cuz during the pandemic they
weren't serving popcorn a lot of the
cinemas uh which I okay sure yeah uh but
I I just didn't want to go cuz if I
can't have the popcorn I don't want to
go genuinely I know it's so dumb but
that's part of the that's part of the
experience for me and having to be able
to like eat that Salted Popcorn just do
and the butter do do you buy popcorn
when you go to I I know I know you guys
don't but for me that is so so crucial
to my cinema going experience my reason
why don't like ordering popcorn at a
cinema is because as you said right it's
usually like The Salted Popcorn right I
don't get I I don't get any other the
[__] soy sauce flavored [__] like all
the corns [__] [__] that right you get
eh it's all right but like I prefer like
just the regular Salted Popcorn right
maybe it's like a bit of butter if
you're in America but what I don't like
is that okay you're eating all this
popcorn right tastes great [__]
amazing but it's also salty so you got
to have a drink with it yeah of course
my tiny bladder can't hold in a piss if
I start drinking it
so I am I know that if I if I have a
bottle of water even if it's like
something this size right and I drink
half of that [__] and halfway into the
film I'm going to be like [__] I'm going
to piss my pants yeah which results me
in missing some of the film which maybe
I don't want to miss it's like 2 minutes
it's like not that bad no I don't want
to well what if it's like an amazing
film I don't want to any I always go and
get the cuz Japan they do half and half
popcorns you get caramel and salted so I
get the half and half and it comes with
two mediumsized drinks I think caramel
popcorn's just all right no but I I love
the love the the distinction between the
two flavors that I'm eating I love the
popcorn this man is describing popcorn
like a
Michelin to me it's so crucial and it's
it's really affordable it's like uh it's
like 12 uh yeah 1,200 Yen uh for that
and like that in the UK that'd be like a
morgage in 15 like it's like ridiculous
and so I mean I don't have a I don't
have a problem with like the price or
anything or people who eat it I just I
personally just don't do it because I
know that I'm going to have to take a
piss break in the middle and maybe I
don't want to did you guys watch
Godzilla minus by the way I have not oh
it's so [__] good watch it it's
really good do it be the hype you reckon
yeah it's a really good film I think
that um the only thing that I I kind of
felt like it it did a little it tried to
have too many Happy Endings when it was
a really like sad film and it kind of
tied things up a little too well I think
but that's like literally my only
criticism it was a really good film and
like did you see Shin Godzilla at all no
no I didn't okay Shin Godzilla was
awesome that was amazing but it's it's
kind of refreshing cuz I I kind of had
felt that a lot of Japanese films for a
while I was really struggling to enjoy
and it was really cool to have it was
really you know they bring out all the
STS for Godzilla man dude it was like it
was great cuz it just the I I mean
honestly it's so rare as well to have I
feel like Japanese media kind of just be
like yeah the government is [__]
incompetent uh and it was kind of Co
Godzilla minus one was about it was kind
of like about it was more that's what
the entire Godzilla franchise is about
well it was more about how in the the
wake of World War II how a lot of the
rebuilding was up to the individual
people and the communi coming together
as opposed to hoping that at least in
this obviously in this this story that
they were they weren't relying on any
they would like yeah the government
isn't going to do [__] we got to get it
done yeah uh and it was just it was a
really cool and like uplifting story
with a lot of heartache and uh just
really well told and fantastic acting
like really good acting for jaes fil
it's so interesting to see the dichotomy
between how Godzilla is treated in Japan
versus how Godzilla is treated in like
Hollywood movies like have you seen like
the tra for the latest Godzilla movie
that's coming out the one where he
another one there's another one what the
[__] where it's Godzilla and Kong and
they have this shot yeah they have how
many rematches they have no no no they
team up this time there's this shot of
Godzilla and Kong running like they oh
wait I've seen this I've seen like
they're coming into like a WWE match or
some some [__] like that I I think I
think Godzilla is and from the Red
Corner it's Kong and Godzilla I think
obviously there's some benefit to
keeping your IP in a certain direction
but I also think that Godzilla is Iconic
and withstand like long-standing enough
where you can have the [__] Pacific
rimk King Kong Godzilla and you can also
have the serious storytelling of of
Godzilla Japan treats it as like you
know how they originally did it with the
the 50s movie which is like you know the
anti-nuclear messaging anti-government
messaging all that kind think then the
West Hollywood was just like big
Godzilla fights another big monster and
he [__] them up but I think that's why
so well is it because of the World War
II setting you know rebuilding after it
with the with the anti- nuclear
sentiment of Godzilla X Kong what is
this a dojan the new Empire basically my
favorite shipping Godzilla and Kong the
new Empire the new Empire I mean
Godzilla looks [__] sick in that new
visual it's it's sick it's just a very
different take of Godzilla you you guys
should watch minus one I really yeah
I've heard really good things about it I
heard good things and I really [__]
enjoyed Shin Godzilla as well which it's
also similar where it's a like a
criticism towards the government
specifically their I guess their
reaction towards the Fukushima incident
use kind of Godzilla as with an Arno
with a good old Arno twist